MALE SPEAKER: He's authored
three books on gamification,
including the newest one which
is just coming out, "The
Gamification Revolution, How
Leaders Leverage Game
Mechanics to Crush the
Competition." So you should
pick that up.
He blogs for sites like
Huffington Post and Mashable.
He's given numerous talks,
including a really great Ted
talk for TedxBrussels titled,
"How Games Make Kids Smarter."
I'm excited to have Gabe here
because gamification is
becoming more and more
recognized as an important
aspect of learning, especially
here at Google.
But as we know, with great
power comes great
responsibility.
So we're very lucky to have
Gabe here and to share his
experiences with us.
So please welcome
Gabe Zichermann.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Thank you.
Thanks very much everybody.
I'm super excited to be here
for the second Google Talk.
It's always nice to have the
Google food and drink the
Google water and so on,
just not the Kool-Aid.
I noticed there's no Kool-Aid.
So talking about gamification,
put this in context first.
I was born in 1974.
And 1974, in addition to being
the year that I was born,
which is an auspicious enough
occasion for us to care, is
also more or less the time that
the modern video game
industry gets up and running.
And it wasn't more than a few
short years later that my
immigrant parents thought, I
think this computer thing is
going to be big someday.
And so maybe we should
get Gabe a computer.
And they bought my
first Vic-20.
It was my first computer,
Vic-20, 1982.
And very shortly thereafter, I
learned my first lesson in
computing when the Commodore 64
came out four weeks later,
after I bought my Vic-20,
making it obsolete.
But like so many people with
their first computers, I'm
sure many of you can relate to
this, I almost immediately
went off in search of the games
that I could play with
my Vic-20, which came mostly in
cartridge or cassette tape
form, which was actually a form
in which software was
once delivered.
And it wasn't long after that
that I started wanting to
learn how to make those games
that were part of that
experience with the computer.
And I started with typing
game books like these--
Usborne books, which some of
you might be familiar with.
And I eventually graduated
to writing some from game
programming books.
And games became an ever larger
part of my life, as
with so many of us who grew up
in that first generation of
contemporary gamers.
All the way through to college,
where I became
obsessed with this game called
Civilization, which I'm sure
has ensnared some of you
and your loved ones.
I played about 8,000 hours of
Civilization, give or take,
during my undergraduate years.
I also managed to graduate
with a degree.
But I spent a lot of time
playing this game.
And so I took that as part of
my passion with games when I
found myself working the
networking industry for a few
years and joined the
games industry.
And I started off working
on the game developers
conference, "Gamasutra" game
developer magazine, which are
the three main trade outlets
in the game space.
And I did cool things like help
launch the Independent
Games Festival, which some of
you might be familiar with.
And after that, I started a
company called Trymedia, which
was the first successful
digital
distribution company in games.
So before Steam, this was a
company that made that happen.
And when we sold the company in
2005, we powered about 4/5
of the world's legitimate
game downloads.
So if you downloaded a game
between 1999 and 2005, thank
you so very much.
After we sold the company,
I had what could best be
described as a crisis
of conscience.
I started to think to myself,
look at all the amazing things
that games have done.
Look at how many people they've
entertained and all
the success that we've had.
Is that all that we'll
ever do with them?
Is entertainment the sum total
of what this powerful medium
is capable of accomplishing?
And don't get me wrong, I
think entertainment is
important and meaningful
in and of itself.
It does not need another
purpose to be
important to society.
But I thought to myself,
we could do more.
And so I started to research.
I started to play around.
I started to build apps.
And out of that came my first
book, "game-based marketing,"
which came out in 2010 and
was followed up by the
"Gamification by Design," which
I wrote for O'Reilly.
And then now, my new book, "The
Gamification Revolution."
And so for the last, however
many years, about seven years,
I spent my life devoted to this
topic of how to use games
to change people's behavior,
change the world.
I now also edit the site,
gamification.co, which is the
main site that covers
that topic.
I run a strategic consultancy
called dopamine, which is the
leading group that helps design
experiences, meaningful
experiences using gamification
engagement science.
And as you heard, I'm the chair
of gamification summit,
or gsummit, which is a
super awesome event.
Some of you will be there.
Hopefully, others of you will
join us either live or online
looking at the top experts who
use this subject area, the
power of games, to change
behavior in
all kinds of spheres.
It's happening in
San Francisco.
And it's at GSummit.com.
But going back to
my childhood.
So games let me do
a few things.
One of the things that I figured
out that very quickly
they allowed me to do is they
allowed me to be somebody else
and experience things that
weren't normal or natural to
my default state of being.
So one of those things was,
obviously, I could be the
athlete in games like
"Decathalon," that I couldn't
be in my regular life.
Or the global sleuth in, "Where
in the World is Carmen
San Diego," which is still one
of my favorite games and
endlessly replayable
even as an adult.
And of course to the tween boy
in me, "Leisure Suit Larry"
gave me some insight into what
it would be like to be an
adult at some point and--
and as you know, it's
very true to life--
have those experiences.
But what I didn't realize at the
time, and science only now
has caught up to some extent,
how significantly those game
experiences were rewiring my
brain and how significantly
they were doing the same
to all of you.
It turns out that in a couple
of key ways, games have a
profound effect on the brain
and on the mind.
And one of those is through the
process of what's called
intrinsic reinforcement.
And basically, the way intrinsic
reinforcement works
is anytime you challenge
yourself to something,
anything at all, doesn't matter
what it is, good or
bad, big or small, and you
achieve that thing, your brain
secretes a little bit of a
magical neurotransmitter
called dopamine.
And dopamine is a pleasure
chemical.
So challenge, achievement,
pleasure.
And the interesting thing about
that loop is, of course,
it explains a great deal of
what's amazing and also kind
of messed up about the world
all in one shot.
Because you can derive pleasure
from things which are
not objectively good.
They don't have to be good in an
ethical, moral, or concrete
sense for you to derive pleasure
of challenging and
achieving that thing.
Now, in the real world, the one
that we're inhabiting in
theory today, we get this
dopamine release very
infrequently.
It doesn't happen
all the time.
It doesn't happen regularly.
We can't beat our personal best
or run our best marathon
time over and over
and over again.
But in the game world, we can
deliver that jolt of dopamine
by design, sometimes hundreds
of times per hour.
A game is an endless series of
little challenges that you
then achieve.
And then you produce dopamine.
And in this loop, in this
constant loop, we train
ourselves to want that
more and more.
That's intrinsic
reinforcement.
We want that release.
The second piece of the science
that's caught up a
little bit is that games can
actually make you smarter.
And this has been the subject
of some debate.
In fact, this research is so
contentious that it's taken 10
years of repeatedly demonstrable
studies by the
same research team to prove that
a game can raise people's
intelligence.
And this game type, this mode
is called n-back, the letter
"n" and then back,
or dual n-back.
It's kind of game rather
than a brand name.
And it's been shown to raise
your intelligence, your IQ
score by as much as four to five
points by playing this
game for as little
as four weeks.
And the halo affect of that
rise can last for
six months or longer.
Kind of astounding when
you think about it.
Pretty amazing that a
game can do that.
Now, I would preface this, I
will say that n-back or dual
n-back is really hard.
So it's not an easy game.
It's not like "Lemonade Stand."
You have to actually
lean in and do it.
And it forms one of the
important lessons about the
power of games and the
power of gamification
to change the world.
But since that time, since my
childhood with games and many
of your childhood with games,
the industry's evolved a
tremendous amount.
The games today are almost
indistinguished--
We can't even see them as the
same thing as they were 30
some odd years ago.
They look amazing.
They're capable of astonishing
things with incredible power,
with incredible clarity, with
incredible sophistication.
And at the same time, our
behavior, our world has
changed substantially from that
time 30 years ago, 30
some odd years ago.
It doesn't look the same at
all as it was before.
And I think that those two
things are connected.
Now, some of us have spent
this time imagining and
dreaming about ways that these
games, this gamer generation,
will help save the world.
They travel even today.
Many of my contemporaries
travel around the world
telling us how great games will
be at solving the world's
problems, how they will help
us to change everything and
fix everything that's
wrong in the world.
But many others seem stuck in a
pattern that hasn't changed
some 30 odd years.
We're still arguing about
whether or not
games are good or bad.
We're still arguing about
whether or not they can teach
children something, whether
they're positive or negative,
whether the addiction that
results from games is better
or worse than other things.
Still arguing about that.
It's the same conversation.
And of course, the omnipresent
question of whether or not
games cause violence, which
continues to be a major theme
in the discussion about games
and their role in the world.
But I'm struck by something on a
repeated basis every time we
have this discussion.
First of all, I am effin bored
as hell of this discussion.
I am sick and tired of having
this argument with people.
It's over, this discussion.
I don't want to have
it anymore.
I don't want to put games or
gamers on trial anymore.
Why is it that games and gamers
are the ones on trial
constantly being asked, what
their purpose is, what purpose
they serve in the world when
our stupid, boring, gray,
dull, irritating, pointless
existences in so many ways are
not the things on trial.
Why isn't every dull
interaction
that we have on trial?
Why are the things that bring
us so much joy, the things
that bring us so much engagement
the things that we
have so many qualms about?
And I'd argue that at the same
time, we're on the cusp of
something very unusual and
interesting, which is, I
believe, an actual evolutionary
step in humanity.
I think we're witnessing the
birth of the next human.
And these things are connected,
in my mind.
And I'm struck by looking at the
rates of, in particular,
autism and ADHD.
I'm sure many of you have
been touched by it.
Of course, the stats tell us
that many of you have been
touched by it, by the
immense growth of it
over the last 30 years.
But in particular now, the stats
say that about one in
every 54 male children
has some form of
autism spectrum disorder.
And over 10% of the American
population has
some kind of ADHD.
And it strikes me that this
is very significant.
At some point in the near term,
this will shift from
being something that we
pathologize, shift from being
something that we medicalize,
to being something that will
be quite normal.
When a sufficient percentage
of the population--
You can project this
graph out.
Most of you are math nerds.
You can project this graph
out yourself, just
the same way I can.
It's not long before these
numbers produce a substantial
minority of the population is no
longer a pathology, that's
no longer an illness, something
that needs to
medicated or something that
needs to be dealt with, but a
substantially different group of
people with a substantially
different way of viewing
the world.
And what makes people in the
autism spectrum and people
with ADHD particularly
interesting is that
it's not all bad.
We think of them as not fitting
and not being able to
relate to the world in
particular ways.
But it turns out that folks with
high functioning autism,
things like Asperger's actually
have a higher level
of fluid intelligence than
the average population.
And fluid intelligence, by the
way, is different from
crystallized intelligence, which
is what we typically
measure on a standard IQ test.
Fluid intelligence is our
ability to problem solve in
novel situations.
It's our ability to, in
circumstances where we don't
really know anything or we don't
have the knowledge, find
solutions to problems,
figure our way out of
boxes, solve things.
And so it's not without
observation that there are
some interesting upsides.
And I want to connect
those dots.
So I started to research the
question of this sort of
adaptation.
And I came across the work of
Nobel Prize winning economist,
Robert Fogel.
And Mr. Fogel has spent his
life researching a concept
called technophysio evolution.
And the concept of technophysio
evolution is, how
is it that technology changes
our evolution, both our
genotype and phenotype
evolution?
So both our genes and how they
are expressed, how that
expresses itself in outcomes
in the world.
This is his area of study.
And after doing a life's work,
crunching an unbelievable
amount of data in his recent
research, they've identified
that technology has been
directly responsible for a
very, very significant change
in human outcomes.
In 1850, the average American
man was 5' 7" and could expect
to live 45 years.
In 1980, the average American
man was 5' 10"
and lived to be 75.
That time interval, that
timespan is so short by
evolutionary standards.
And after crunching all the
data, it became very clear
there was no other answer but
technology to explain how that
occurred, various technologies,
but how that occurred.
And so why would technology's
influence on our evolution,
both genotype and phenotype,
be restricted?
If you can think, our longevity,
our vibrancy, our
health is such a big thing.
It's a very complicated thing.
If it can influence that, what
else is in influencing?
What other things are
technologies, and particularly
really engaging technologies,
doing to our
sense of well being?
And so it strikes me--
"Revenge of the Nerds," it
strikes me that we've come
upon a time in which certain
kinds of characteristics,
certain kinds of human
characteristics are no longer
things that we need
to select against.
So now, it no longer hurts your
ability to reproduce, if
that's the objective, certainly
from an evolutionary
biology standpoint.
It no longer hurts your ability
to reproduce if you're
not so good socially.
If you're not as good at reading
social cues in this
generation, you probably are
not going to have a huge
problem finding a mate
and having kids.
And that's been the
case for a while.
And in fact, our society has
increasingly shifted to
valuing our ability to process
and interact with machines
versus our ability to process
and interact with each other,
which is one of the
characteristics of people with
autism spectrum disorder.
It's a response to that.
So those people who are able to
do better with machines and
process with their brains
technology, math, and that
kind of interaction have
some sort of advantage
in our world today.
And so it seems to me like these
things put together,
these technology pressures,
particularly the power of
games, are producing this
interesting evolutionary step.
And those people who have this
new capability, who have this
new and different characteristic
are not to be
medicalized.
It's not a pathology.
It's the future of people.
And they're already
walking among us.
There's no ignoring the
evidence, for those of you
with a young child.
There's no ignoring the evidence
of their intuitive
connection with technology and
that increasing funnel and
pressure that we put them on to
engage with that technology
in early days.
This is only intensifying.
It's only becoming
more serious.
This evolutionary step is
something that the optimist,
the writers, the visionaries
have talked
about for a long time.
And I think for many of you
who loved comic books, who
loved video games as kids, you
had sort of hoped that if we
had a human evolutionary step
in our lifetime, that those
people would have superpowers.
I think we can all agree it
would be really cool.
And they'd be really easy to
spot, because they'd be flying
above us and turning
water into ice.
But I posit that this is
actually happening and it is a
kind of super power.
And that superpower's
manifesting itself every day.
What's interesting to me about
this particular evolution from
the millennial generation
forward is that for many
folks, particularly older folks,
the millennials in this
tight gamer influence generation
is something that
they just don't understand.
It's something that's producing
a lot of friction.
And yet, it's suggested that
this particular generation
doesn't have problems as much
as these particular
generations have strengths.
And they're demonstrating those
strengths by running
rings around the established
order all the time.
And those rings are showing
up in ever more increasing
frequency the more and
more that we look.
And it poses a real challenge
for those of us not on that
side of the fence, those of us
perhaps a little bit older
already established in
our jobs in industry.
Google the phrase "managing
millennials," for example.
I know many of you
are quite young.
Many of you are in the
millennial generation.
But you have to know that many
older folks, people more my
age and even older, are having
a lot of, shall we say, ennui
about managing millennials.
Just for your own edification,
Google it and see all the
frustration people--
Millenials are so
hard to manage.
They need constant positive
reinforcement.
They're never happy
with anything.
They think they're entitled
to everything.
I look at that and I'm like, so
you're taking the smartest,
fastest thinking, most
technologically literate, most
socially connected, most
ethically grounded generation
in history, dismissing them
because you can't figure out
how to manage them the way
they need to be managed.
Let me tell you what
will happen.
If you can't figure out how to
make an environment that's
engaging to them, they'll leave
and start competitors.
Because there's nothing holding
that generation and
their younger cohort to working
in major corporations.
Similarly, from the marketing
standpoint, if you don't make
your products and services
engaging enough, if you don't
think about them the way this
intensively changed, new human
thinks about marketing a product
experiences, you too
will lose them.
Take this case study.
A few months ago, a major car
maker came to me, one of the
world's largest makers, and
said, Gabe, we have a problem.
I was like, OK, what's
your problem?
And they're like, kids don't
want to drive anymore.
For the first time since
the introduction of the
automobile, the interest of
teenagers in driving in the
United States is
on the decline.
It's never been seen before.
And there's lots of different
research.
And I said, why?
Let's look at the research.
And the reasons that are cited
are the environment, which the
millennial and younger
generations, the [INAUDIBLE]
generation are really
concerned with.
The cost of driving a car, also
prominent in people's minds.
But the main reason, according
to this automaker's research
was that kids can't Instagram
and tweet while
they're behind the wheel.
Not kidding you.
So instead of not
Instagramming, they're not driving.
Let's put that into
perspective.
If you told me five years ago
that some photo sharing app
was going to undo five
generations of intrinsically
built-in American personality
and behavior, that connection
between Americans and their
cars, between teenage
Americans and their
cars, right?
Think about this indoctrination
that you get as
a teenager.
If you had told me that
Instagram was going to kill
the car, I'd have
laughed at you.
But the writing's on the wall.
People will give up things that
are so dear to them in
pursuit of pleasure and positive
reinforcement.
They go where the pleasure is.
It's a sort of hedonistic
principle.
And to the old canard of
violence in video games--
every time some terrible tragedy
happens that often in
between, a debate erupts
about the effect of
video games on violence.
And even if you choose to ignore
all the studies that
say the games do not generate
violence in people who are
naturally not predisposed to
violence, we can also all
agree that games are excellent
training tools.
And so if you are predisposed
to violence and you like to
use video games, you probably
have gotten a fair amount of
education on how to do that.
Now, let me ask you this.
If we're going to have this
argument about games and
violence in society, what
are you going to do?
Ban games?
You need to get rid of them?
You going to shove that
back in the box?
Maybe the more pertinent
question should be, how are
you going to defend yourself
against somebody who spent
10,000 or 20,000 hours training
on how to commit
violence when they decide
that they want to?
Your police officers, your Army
lieutenants do not have
the same amount of training that
a 16-year-old boy playing
video games has, in terms of
total numbers of hours.
And they never will.
They'll retire from the police
force without ever seeing that
much action as you will in four
or five years of violent
video game play.
The only way to do that, the
only way to do it, whether
it's that--
I know that was a little
heavy, OK.
But I understand.
But we have to have
this conversation.
We have to have it.
People are too polarized
about this.
We have to have the
real conversation.
And no matter what it is, you're
not putting this game
genie back in the box.
You're not going to do it.
So what you have to do no matter
where you sit in the
ecosystem is level the
playing field.
Changing this next generation
consumer, this next generation
human is less powerful of a
strategy and less effective of
a strategy, as I'll argue and
I'll show you, as making the
thing that you do, the position
that you're trying to
advocate for, whether that's
your business, society, the
government, your non-profit,
or even
your safety more gamelike.
And so we arrive at this topic
called gamification.
And the way that we think
about gamification is
gamification is the process of
engaging users and changing
behavior using the best ideas
from games, loyalty programs,
and behavioral economics.
It's a way of leveling
the playing field.
It's a way of bringing the best
ideas from games to this
thing that you're doing, which
maybe isn't games, and
leveraging that to create the
kind of engagement that you
need to change that
sort of behavior.
In looking at the research, we
found that there were three
characteristics that a system
had to have in order to be
engaging, particularly to this
next generation of consumer.
It had to have feedback,
friends, and fun.
And the more feedback, friends,
and fun that a system
has, the more effective it is at
changing people's behavior.
Feedback, friends, and fun,
these are the characteristics.
And although much of this
evolutionary shift that I've
been talking about is something
that rests below our
observable level, so it's not
something that most of us are
keenly aware of, I think.
We don't feel like there's a
next human walking among us.
It turns out that intuitively,
many businesses have actually
been talking to this new
consumer and designing for
this new consumer.
And it's an interesting case
study in the free market and
that profit motive, and how in
response to pressure, some
organizations have stepped it
up and figured out a way to
leverage gamification and take
leadership even before there
was clear evidence
to support this.
So one of those examples,
certainly on
the marketing side--
And it's no surprise that
marketers are first, because
they're the first people to
say, hey, our ads are not
working the way they
should anymore.
People are not paying
attention to
our messages anymore.
Everyone knows that our social
media marketing is fake.
So one of the most interesting
case studies for this comes
from a company called Autodesk,
which many of you
are familiar with as a creator
high end 3D modeling software.
And they have, like many
software makers, a free to
play, free trial version.
Afterwards, you can buy
a paid version.
Autodesk realized that people
were getting all excited.
I'm going to do 3D modeling.
It's really cool.
I want to make 3D stuff.
And they would download the
trial version of the product,
fully featured, industry
standard product.
And then people would get
confused and stop using it and
therefore, never buy
the product.
So they said we have to
have a better way.
We've got to connect with this
new consumer in a new way and
come up with a way to get them
to buy this product.
And so what they did was they
gamified the free trial of
their 3D modeling software.
They created quests, which are
inspired by Carmen San Diego--
even though I don't know that
they would say that publicly--
where basically, you have to
solve puzzles for each feature
of the product.
So you're traveling through
the world and solving a
puzzle as you go.
And to solve each puzzle, you've
got to learn the basic
element of the product, like how
to model something, how to
rotate a model, how to light
something, so all these
different features.
And through this process,
Autodesk has raised total time
in its trial versions by 40% and
increased revenue by 15%.
It increased sales.
The seat of their software
goes for $3,500.
So 15% increase is not an
insignificant number.
Would be significant at any
company, but it's particularly
jarring in that context.
And that's by creating these
opportunities to connect with
consumers in a way that's
more meaningful.
Or another fun example,
this time from
the pizza chain Domino's.
Domino's built this game called
"Pizza Hero." And in
this game, which is available
for your iOS devices and also
Android devices, you play a
pizzaolo or pizzaola, someone
who makes pizzas.
You have to learn how to knead
the dough, spin the dough up,
get the ingredients,
put them on.
Once you've mastered how to do
that, you could actually
submit your pizza to be baked
at your local Domino's.
So as an output of the game,
you can say, hey
make this for me.
And then they bake it and
deliver you the pizza that you
made through this game.
And if you're especially good
at it, Domino's will invite
you to apply for a job at the
company making pizzas, which
of course is amusing.
But this is a real
business problem.
This is a company that's got to
hire a lot of people every
year, big turnover.
In the first seven weeks of the
product roll out, hundreds
of thousands of people played
Domino's "Pizza Hero." And it
resulted in millions of dollars
worth of incremental
revenue to the company.
They've been a little bit more
mum on the number of employees
they've hired as
a result of it.
But nonetheless, a really,
really interesting case study.
But the use of gamification
isn't isolated to marketing.
Other companies taking a
leadership position thinking
about this next generation of
consumers have started to
apply these principles to human
resources and to the
enterprise and to business
process.
And one of those is IBM, which
built a business process
management platform called
innov8, off of which they
developed a couple of
games that make
use of this BPM concept.
And one of those games, by
example, is called "City
Manager." it's kind of a "Sim
City" for people who actually
run cities.
So if you're really a city
manager, it's the kind of
thing you might play.
Today, IBM's little game
experiment, this little game
that IBM has put out on the web,
is the number one lead
generator for the IBM
corporation worldwide, is this
game that they put on their
website, the inov8 platform.
Pretty cool stuff.
It's actually a lot of fun.
Or take as an example,
"Plantville," from the German
engineering company Siemens,
which most of you, I'm sure,
are familiar with.
So Siemens built this game
called "Plantville," in which
you run a plant or factory
or some kind of
facility like that.
The crazy part about
"Plantville" is right now as
we're talking, something like
20,000 or 25,000 people are
playing "Plantville," of which
the majority are people who
run plants for a living.
So just to put this in a
perspective, you go to your
job running a factory all
day until 6 o'clock.
Then you come home, take your
pants off, grab a sandwich,
and sit down and play plant
manager all night long until
you go to bed.
It sounds a little
crazy, right?
It's a little crazy,
until you start
putting this into context.
And you start remembering, as
some of you may have seen
during the Iraq and Afghanistan
conflicts, news
reports ran these stories about
soldiers would go out,
do a sortie, come back to base,
take a shower, sit down,
and play war games.
Some of you may have seen
that in the news.
This is a kind of similar
phenomenon.
The basic idea is that whatever
it is that you do for
a job, you go into that job with
really big expectations
about what your career's
going to hold.
You have a fantasy about
what that job is.
And then once you get into a
day to day, your reality's
more narrow.
But you were in it because
you had a real
passion for that thing.
And you still maybe want
to play with it.
Take this example.
So let's say you're the nuclear
plant manager playing
"Plantville." Every day you
come to your job at this
nuclear plant.
This nuclear plant, you come in
every day hoping that today
is not the day that the
plant melts down.
But you kind of hope it is,
just a little bit, right?
But it would be terrible
if it was.
But it would be kind awesome.
But it would also be horrifying
and really good.
It's complicated.
You train your whole life
as a nuclear plant
manager for that meltdown.
You've trained and trained
and trained.
You've done all the training,
mostly on paper.
It would be bad if
that happened.
But also, it would be kind of
cool to test your limits, to
know what you're capable of
doing, to actually see
yourself in that context.
But again, the use of
gamification by leading edge
businesses isn't limited
to marketing or HR.
To address this next generation
of challenges and
this next consumer, companies
are also using it in a
strategic way.
Take, for example, the United
Kingdom's Department of Work
and Pensions.
It alone is the single biggest
part of the UK government in
terms of budget spent.
They cover 28% of the total
budget of the UK, just this
one department.
And they were looking for ways
of optimizing their business
and ways of improving the
way that they work.
So they launched this concept
called Idea Street, which is a
stock market for ideas.
Anyone in the company can
propose a concept.
And then people buy and sell
shares in that idea just like
in the stock market
to rank them.
In the first 90 days, Idea
Street generated over 1,400
different concepts, different
ideas that were vetted by the
market and saved them 30
million pounds in cost
savings, just from the launch
of that idea, demonstrating
how you can do it.
And when we talk about the
civil service, it's not
usually like idea
rich environment
in which we're operating.
So it's particularly
challenging.
Or another example that I really
like comes from the
University of Washington,
a project called Foldit.
And some of you might be
familiar with this.
But basically the premise is
in order to do advanced
disease intervention or drug
discovery, we have to be able
to understand the small protein
structures of the
world around us, like
DNA and RNA.
But we can't actually do that
under a microscope, because we
don't have microscopes that can
see the structure clearly.
So we do it through a process
of folding, where we model
them out and then use math
models to figure out whether
it's accurate or not.
Now, the process of folding
is very time consuming.
And it turns out that machines
are not very good at protein
folding, because they're not
very good at defining symmetry
without making mistakes.
They're not terrible, but
they're not great.
Humans, on the other hand,
are intuitively quite
good at this function.
They're very good at finding
symmetry in things.
So researchers at the University
of Washington took
their machine learning protein
folding product, called
Rosetta, and built a human based
protein folding game
called Foldit on top of it.
And Foldit had a colossal
breakthrough just a little
over a year ago.
Scientists had been working
for 15 years to solve this
elemental protein structure
in the fight against HIV.
15 years, they've
been stumped.
And Foldit players, 49,000
people playing Foldit, solved
that protein structure in 10
days that had stopped people
for 15 years.
Now, what's super cool about it
is not that you can get a
community of people to engage
in a challenge.
Because you can certainly
do that.
You've seen that.
You have SpaceShipOne hanging
in your foyer.
You know that you can get
communities of people engaged
in a challenge.
What's particularly exciting
about the Foldit example is
that 50% of the people who
played Foldit had no math or
science background whatsoever.
They did this tough math and
science problem without
actually knowing how to do it,
without ever having receive
training for it.
And it's a very, very
interesting case study.
When you give people a sense
of purpose and you build a
game that's engaging or fun, you
can activate that smarter,
better, faster element of
this evolving consumer.
Or take the example of Nike.
So many of you are familiar with
Nike+, a combination of
hardware and software device
that enables us
to track our movement.
When Nike+ was first conceived
in 2004, Nike was not the top
choice for hard core runners.
They were the second or
third shoe of choice
for a hard core runner.
New Balance and Asics were much
more popular with the
hard core runner.
And Nike, seeing the trend of
mobile technology, built
Nike+, which allows us to
keep track of how we do.
Today, 5 million people will
use Nike+ to track their
performance.
And what it's done is it's
changed the meaning of being a
sportswear and apparel
company.
It's changed what Nike is
fundamentally, in a strategic
way, from the bottom up.
It used to be a company that
sold footwear and shirts and
shorts and pants.
And today, for those 5 million
people and the people who
joined Nike+ and buy the fuel
band every single day, Nike's
a wish fulfillment company.
Nike is a business.
Nike is a brand that helps you
get where you want to go in
life, for real.
Not just in advertising, not
just in Mad Men language, but
for real, every day.
Every step you take along your
way, while you're sweating,
while you're aching, Nike is
there pushing you on, urging
you forward, telling
you to do better.
They fulfill your dreams of
being who you want to be.
And oh by the way, they sell
some shoes and apparel.
But the writing's on the wall.
The future for that business is
as a software company, not
as a hardware company.
At the heart, these examples and
the dozens of others that
we talk about in the
gamification revolution was
why I wrote this book.
While so many people are sitting
around arguing about
whether or not the millennials
can be managed and trying to
figure out whether or not we can
adapt to the challenges of
the future, some businesses
already are.
And they're using gamification
and those principles to gain a
strategic competitive advantage
over others.
They're dominating markets.
They're transforming the
definition of their businesses
and some non-profits and
governments, as well, as
you've seen, by using these
concepts of gamification.
So that's the contents
of my book.
And we also built for the book
the world's first gamified
social reading application
called ReadSocial, which you
can download for free if you get
a copy of the book and see
a new way of engaging
with this content.
So for many people, the concept
of gamification was a
sort of tactical idea.
It's like, oh, we've got this
little engagement problem we
need to solve.
Let's put some game
processing on it.
Let's sprinkle game
sugar on it.
Let's get it more gamey and
then the problems will
magically solve themselves.
And the point of this
gamification revolution, the
point of the book, and the
point of this work is to
highlight that this has ceased
to be a tactical environment.
This is starting to be a
strategic environment, one in
which companies that acknowledge
this new consumer
gain a significant advantage.
And so one of the most frequent
questions, of course,
in all that I've been
talking about--
I've been only talking about
these younger generation, this
next evolution of humanity.
But it turns out, and this is
the bonus for all of us, the
techniques in gamification work
just as well on older
people, they're just
not begging for it.
They're not sitting
around arguing
that it needs to happen.
It's this new gamer generation
that's on the forefront,
that's pushing it forward, the
ones that are disconnecting
from the existing experiences.
But everything that we do for
them, we can also do for the
older generations.
And that's just a big bonus.
So as we look forward, as I look
forward over the next few
years and look at this shift in
society, it strikes me that
what we all need to do is we all
need to start connecting
with this idea that the next
human is here, they
walk among us now.
Many of you are them.
And some of you have
them as children.
They're a new kind of person
with a new and special skill.
They're intimately connected to
the technologies that many
of you have built and our
parents built and the world is
delivering.
They've adopted, based on those
technologies, from the
kind of people that we were
to the kind of people
that we will be.
And we stand in between two
kinds of humans, one based on
the old model where technology
was a nice to have and one
based on the new model where
technology is the context
through which we interact with
ourselves and with each other.
And in the context of this
inescapable conclusion for me,
we find that it's necessary
for us to start, I think,
embracing this idea,
internalizing the notion of
how we connect with that
particular consumer, that next
person, that next member of
society, whatever they may be.
And to remember that while we
may think of some of them as
needing our help, needing our
assistance, needing medicine,
needing remediation, needing
their support, maybe it's us
that needs the help.
Maybe it's the slow, gray world
that we come from into
the bright, shiny feedback
friends and fun filled world
that we're entering that's the
one that needs to be fixed,
the one that needs
to be helped.
And so I hope that this will
be something that all of us
can feel as a potential
opportunity for you in your
business, for you in your
career, for the world that we
live in and that you'll join
me in this amazing, amazing
journey as we gamify
the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So one of the things
that always interests me is
keeping users motivated,
particularly in algorithms
wrapping a human into it.
What are some of the ways that
you've seen that people are
using motivational systems to
keep users engaged for long
terms without any kind of cliff
at the end, where they
just lose interest and stop
playing the game?
GABE ZICHERMANN: So it's not
possible to design an
experience that is a perpetual
motion machine for engagement.
We don't have the ability to
write one set of code that
will forever be interesting to
people, because one of the
characteristics of people--
not even this new generation
of consumer that I've been
talking, but all people--
is that we quickly habituate
to stimuli.
So just so that we could put the
science into context, it
just came out.
The research was published
recently, I think, in
"Science." And they wrote it up
in the "New York Times." So
they said that the average
romantic relationship between
people spend two years in a
state of romantic affection.
And then after about two years,
switches to become
companionship affection.
So we stop waking up every day
going, oh my god, my partner's
so amazing and start waking up
every day and going, OK, we
got to take the kids
to school.
I'm glad this person is here.
So romance shifts to
companionship.
Now, many couples when they
encounter that transition,
they feel badly about
themselves.
Because they're like, I somehow
failed in this.
My relationship is no longer as
hot and fresh and exciting
as it was before.
The science behind that
is called habituation.
And all of your human senses,
your brain is wired to
eventually habituate to stimuli,
that is to say, to
normalize stimuli.
Think about why that's important
evolutionarily.
Like a really bad smell, if you
didn't habituate to it,
but it was perpetual,
you'd go crazy.
Background noise, if you don't
learn habituate to that kind
of background noise,
you'd go crazy.
Right now, if a caveman was
unfrozen and became a lawyer
and showed up here,
they would note--
It's an SNL joke.
They would note that there was a
loud hum in the room, like a
very loud machine hum,
because they've
never heard that before.
We don't hear it anymore,
because we've
habituated to it.
But it's all around
you all the time.
So habituation is the enemy of
long term engagement design.
Every time a stimulus is
presented and is presented
over and over again, eventually
people become
immune to it.
One technique is to do what's
called operant conditioning,
which is slot machine effect.
If you can never predict the
reward, ever, in any way, and
you can't predict its timing or
its size or its frequency,
then in theory, you'll be
forever pressing a pedal
trying to get that
thing to happen.
But people even find
that disturbing.
So the key is whatever you're
going to do to design long
term engagement for users
requires you to design it in
the long term.
Design it early, middle,
and late game.
Continue to invest in it.
Continue to evolve
it over time.
They're clearly some games like
Nike+ which continue to
be played over the long term.
"World of Warcraft" is played
over the long term.
But make no mistake
that those are
continuously being expanded.
Those are continuously
being evolved.
They're always being changed
and updated.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
your talk today.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Thank
you for being here.
AUDIENCE: I have basically
two questions.
So the first line is, are there
any types of problems
where you would not
encourage to use
gamification to solve them?
And the second one is around the
mechanics of gamification.
What are the good sources--
maybe, I'm not sure.
I just bought your book.
I'm not sure if you talk
about it in the book.
What are the components of
a gamification strategy?
What are the attributes and
how do you combine them to
gamify a problem?
GABE ZICHERMANN: So your second
question, I'll do the
mechanics first.
So there is a kind of
methodology that I've laid out
in "Gamification by Design,"
which steps through how we
gamify something.
And I don't think that there's
one cookie cutter actual set
of mechanics that you can use.
I don't think we could say,
do a, then b, then c.
We can't build a repeating
algorithm to make gamification
work every time.
Because in practice, whenever
we do that, it ends up
becoming kind of boring.
So everyone has the
same thing.
And then nobody cares
about it anymore.
So you have to be original.
But you can use a methodology
to go about process of
designing gamification.
And it probably won't surprise
you to know that we use
gamification to design
gamification.
So it's a little meta,
but a lot of fun.
And if you get a chance, I
do them live workshops.
I do them in the books.
Also, we have some online
resources that you can follow
to help you.
So visit gamification.co.
It's got some great resources
for the mechanics.
The second question, like
situations where we don't use
or shouldn't use gamification,
or where it doesn't work.
So I get asked this
question a lot.
And I usually give one answer,
but I want to give you a
different answer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Yeah, yeah.
Why not?
So here's the thing.
I've tried to of express this
probably a couple different
ways today.
So I just want to go back
to it for a second.
I don't really think that
there's any situation in which
we shouldn't be thinking
about how to gamify it.
Because every single idea,
concept, product, business in
the world lives or dies by
its consumer engagement.
Everything.
I tend to describe it as
a last mile problem.
It is the last mile problem of
every idea, especially in
technology.
You've got a great concept, an
amazing product, just like the
other 5 million people here in
the valley coming up with
their great ideas, launching
their problem products.
And where do they all
end up failing?
They all end up feeling because
they're not able to
get user adoption.
That's where we have
the last mile part.
It's not we don't have great
ideas, because we have lots of
great ideas.
It's that we don't have methods
for actually getting
people to do that thing.
And no matter how good our ideas
are, if people don't do
that thing, then our idea
isn't worth squat.
It turns out that engagement
behavior change, itself, is
actually, I think, the currency
on which companies
are priced.
So the more businesses are able
to change behavior and
the more you in your own career
are able to touch your
examples of behavior change,
the more people
will pay for you.
That's what they're
paying for.
You can call it traffic.
But the discussion is shifting
from traffic to engagement.
And that's the currency of our--
the coin of the realm,
if you will.
So gamify everything.
And probably, you won't
have a choice, p.s.
That's the other piece of it.
This next consumer isn't going
to care unless the experience
has feedback, friends,
and fun.
They're just not
going to care.
Just ignore it.
Oh, this doesn't have enough
fun in it, so I'm
not going to do it.
And I don't care how good it
is for me or how good it is
for the world.
It's got to of have feedback,
friends, and fun.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
I do a lot of coaching.
And they've trained us to do
games in the practicing.
So we play baseball.
And instead of just playing
catch with them,
you have this game.
So they designed this game.
They're running this game.
So my question is, the game,
I didn't realize, was so
exciting by the players.
But have you seen things we
need to watch for on the--
So the goal is to make sure they
play well in the game,
the actual game, not
the practice game.
Do I need to watch out for--
So there's a lot of feedback in
that practice game you do
for ground balls.
But will it to translate into
when they have their game?
Because baseball's
kind of slow.
GABE ZICHERMANN: It
is kind of slow.
AUDIENCE: It's a one person
kind of thing.
And when we play this game, it's
like they're so active.
And they're cheering
on each other.
But in the game, you're
kind of, you know--
GABE ZICHERMANN: So there's a
lot of interesting research on
how to design feedback loops
for optimal outcomes.
And there's no clear answer
for how to do that.
There's not one ring to rule
them all when it comes to how
to design a feedback loop.
AUDIENCE: One of the
question is--
So we're getting the feedback
in the game practicing.
But in the actual, when we
want them to perform--
GABE ZICHERMANN: What's the
purpose of a practice game?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's not
a practice game.
It's just this, for
the ground balls.
They line up.
And we throw ground
balls to them.
They get points.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Why?
AUDIENCE: They find it fun.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Are you doing
it because they find it fun or
are you doing it because
that will improve their
performance?
AUDIENCE: We want them to
improve their performance in
the actual game.
GABE ZICHERMANN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I wonder, like
in the game, it's so slow.
In the actual game, it's so
slow, they might not even get
the chance to actually
catch a ground ball.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Right?
AUDIENCE: They perform lower
in the real situation.
GABE ZICHERMANN: So a
couple quick things.
One is, if you're going to
design a proxy experience for
people, so you let's say you
were designing a simulator to
simulate being a pilot.
Many of you have seen
those aircraft
simulators on TV or movies.
Some of you have probably
been in one.
It's kind of awesome.
I really want to go in one.
So that simulator has to
be super realistic.
That simulator cannot be
partially realistic.
It can't suffer from, what's
called the uncanny valley,
which some of you might know
from game design, where you
get something that looks and
feels a lot like reality, but
then isn't reality.
So you sit there spending a lot
of your energy figuring
out, is it real or isn't it,
instead of just being in the
experience, or constantly
being pulled in and out.
If you build a simulator to
simulate the experiences that
somebody's supposed to have in
real life and that simulator
is better than real life, why do
you think that people would
want to do the thing in real
life, as much as they would
want to do the simulator?
So that's a genuine issue.
It's similar to the nuclear
plant manager thought example
that I gave you earlier, which
is you do this exciting
training thing.
And the actual thing
a sort of boring.
So one piece of advice
I would give is, make
baseball more exciting.
We could all benefit from that,
if that's within your
power to do.
If it's not within your power
to do, I would look for ways
to make that simulation more
like actual baseball and maybe
put people on different tracks
depending on their actual
skill level.
So if they are more highly
skilled and more highly
motivated, maybe they will be
fine doing the high speed
practice, because they're being
driven to play that
other game a different way
versus your average player or
below average player, for whom
as soon as the attention
shifts out of the--
They drop out of attention,
they're not going to be
engaged anymore.
I'd like to see your new
baseball, Baseball 2.0.
I might even play it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GABE ZICHERMANN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In terms of enterprise
gamification, what
are the most common stumbling
blocks you've seen, maybe in
your consulting work, where
do things go wrong or
where do they fail?
GABE ZICHERMANN: So the biggest
mistake that companies
make all the time, this
happens all the time.
So it's like a company will be
like, alright well, we, want
to gamify an employee
interaction, because we're
trying to improve throughput,
improve outcomes, whatever.
So my first question to them is
always, how are you going
to get them to use it?
Because 4/5 of enterprise
software implementations fail,
more or less.
So how are you going to get
people to use this thing?
And typically, especially if
it's HR driven, the company
will say, well, they're
going to have to do.
So by Fiat, that's the method
for delivering new software.
And the truth is, people don't
like being told what to do.
It doesn't matter how
fun the game is.
If I preface my gamify solution
by saying, you must
play this game, you're probably
going to be like, no,
not so much.
So that's a really
big mistake.
We have to make enterprise
engagement design to the same
standards as consumer
engagement.
You'd never try to get
your customers to do
something like that.
Why get your employees to
do something like that?
And the more we start to
realize, and I talk about this
in the evolution of this
consumer point, that same
person who's just as distracted
by their smartphone
at home, who can't watch--
Crazy stat.
The last month, 80% of the
American population has
watched television with a second
or third screen open
while watching.
Now, it wasn't that long ago
that TV was the distraction.
And now, we need a distraction
from the distraction just to
feel like our brains
are functioning.
Are you frustrated at the movies
when you go that you
can't open your phone?
I am.
I think about it all the time.
It's like, I want to do
something, but I have to just
watch this movie.
And so set against that
backdrop, why would employees
suddenly not become normal
humans when they walk through
the door at work?
What is it about the walking
through the doorway at the
office that suddenly makes
them not distracted, that
suddenly makes the not
hedonistic, that suddenly
makes them not want to follow
feedback, friends, and fun?
Nothing, p.s.
Historically, we've
depended on this.
We've all been part of this
shared delusion that the
office is somehow not
like the free market
for people's attention.
And in practice, it's
no different.
So to build successful
enterprise gamification, you
have to start thinking about
your employees as consumers,
think about them in the same
context as consumers, and
design that experience with
that same idea in mind.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is, can you use
gamification to actually
reduce engagement, like to
addictions or products like
that, which you actually
would like to--
GABE ZICHERMANN: Yes.
In fact, two of the most
successful examples of
gamification are Alcoholics
Anonymous and Weight Watchers,
both of which are behavior
cessation games.
And in fact, Weight Watchers
employs a fair number of game
designers to tweak
the design of it.
And they're two of the most
successful behavior cessation
systems in the world.
They have many of the same core
design principles of the
other gamified examples that
we've talked about.
So they've got points.
And they've got badges.
And they have levels.
And they've got achievements
and some
degree of leader boards.
So they've got all
the mechanics.
But what makes them especially
powerful is that they're all
about helping people
achieve mastery.
And any time you design your
experience, something
gamified, we spend a lot of
time talking about helping
people achieve mastery, how
gamification drives mastery.
And the more you're able to
drive mastery in people, the
more loyalty they give you,
the more control they give
you, the more confidence they
impart in your system.
So basically, if you give
somebody the mastery over
something that they want
to control, they're
loyal to you forever.
So consider this.
You run into somebody
on the street.
You haven't seen them
in five years.
You're like, oh my god,
you look amazing.
You've lost so much weight.
You look amazing.
They turn to you and they're
like, oh yeah, I did it at
Weight Watchers.
How'd you do it?
But it's not Weight Watchers.
You actually had to do
diet and exercise.
The person did the work.
They did the work, the same work
that everybody else does.
They just used Weight Watchers
as the system to do it.
When the system delivers
mastery, people will replace
their sense of self
accomplishment with the system
as the identity.
They do that all the time.
That's its kind of
loyalty side.
So you can change behavior when
people want to change
their behavior by using
those systems.
If your question was whether,
can you force people to change
their behavior?
It depends on whether
or not you believe
people have free will.
If you believe they have free
will, then you cannot force
them to do anything.
If you don't believe they have
free will, then you can
certainly force them to
do certain things.
AUDIENCE: So seguing from
addiction, all of these seem
to be about moving people who
aren't already addicted to
gamification process
into this process.
What do you do when people's
limited engagement is maxed
out on all these things
we've built, these
feedback cycles for--
Like, how do you make them do
Foldit instead of more cow
tipping on Facebook?
GABE ZICHERMANN: Well, I think
it's just an arms race.
So just like everything else
that you have to do, any other
kind of behavior change or user
engagement system, over
time they lose their efficacy.
And you have to overcome
their habituation.
Thankfully today, the market
is more wide open than you
would think.
Even in writing "Gamification
Revolution," where we were
researching and looking at
these companies that were
really doing this strategically,
that were
really crushing the competition
with gamification,
there's not that
many examples.
It's like we had 500 examples
to choose from.
We didn't have that many
where they're really
doing it that well.
So one of the things about
gamification is it's a
relatively new trend with
pretty deep roots.
And because we're in the tech
business, we've heard the term
for three years.
And we're like, oh everyone's
doing it.
But look around Google.
How much of it is actually
being done?
Some of it is like conceptual
people want to do it.
Sometimes we dipped our toe
in the water somewhere.
But not that many companies are
actually doing it doing
it, deliberately doing
it, purposefully.
So the market is still fairly
open in most categories.
And I would say even in
categories where gamification
has been particularly
successful, like
the wellness category--
I challenge you to find a
wellness startup in the last
two years that isn't a
gamification-based wellness startup.
It's hard to find one.
Even in the wellness category
like the best performer, Nike+
arguably, or RunKeeper or
Fitbit, one of those, none of
them are A plusses.
Not to be critical, but none of
them have knocked it out of
the ballpark.
Nike+ is great, but it's
5 million people.
But it's 5 million people.
It's not 500 million people.
So we still have work to do.
We've still got a
long way to go.
I won't stand up here
and tell you that I
have all the answers.
What I have is clarity that
there's a real challenge.
And it's going to require the
effort of all people doing
whatever it is that they're
doing to lean into actually
make that a reality.
Thanks to you.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
And if you're a Twitter person,
you can chat with me
on Twitter.
I'm @gzicherm.
Thank you everybody.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.